hello when welcome to this video bring
ya back with the coverage for the
candidates tournament after I couldn't
do the videos for two days my voice was
just to intern in a gap the shape of it
was too bad now it's a bit better it's
not like I'm completely back to one
hundred percent again but it's good
enough to do videos yeah so what am I
going to do am basically behind three
rounds so I'm going to do in this video
which will cover rounds four and five in
one video and it will be a little bit
less detailed for the games I just feel
like games that are three or two days
all them I mean you probably have seen
them already so it's a just a bit late
to do a full fledged commentary on them
I will do however around six and then
full-length let's say and this will be a
separate video so let's have a look at
what happened in rounds four and five um
I still want to UM check all the games
quickly and focus on some key moments
okay that is filled aronian from round
form and we have an English opening swig
less playing very versatile um fashion
in this event trying different openings
here c4s plate probably because Aronian
has the Berlin is this repertoire and so
we get this English opening here with
you for it's an interesting sideline um
it's some quite remarkable how black
strategy is after he for he takes on c3
and beat eggs and now black plays a move
c6 blacks idea here's to play d5 and
this is an interesting moment this is
actually the reason why I want to talk
about this game at all it's not super
interesting in the the later stages of
game but it shows that sometimes there's
a misconception about yeah when a
position should be opened and when a
position should be closed or how bishops
for examples fair in close and open
positions here why it has the bishop
pair so you would imagine that black
should try to keep the position closed
and not open it too quickly so what
about something that just keep the
position closed yeah black plays g6 for
example yeah wyd will probably play like
three black girls like 96 and 92 and
Bishop e6 and the h3 and maybe queen d 7
and then f4 and then you suddenly
realize that blacks position is pretty
terrible I know that this was very
cooperative way with Queen D 7 NB should
be six but the thing is white has from a
purely central control point of view a
very very good control after he gets in
d3 and the whole position like this I'm
sorry that was the game the whole
position somehow gets frozen in the
middle if this is established for white
he often has chances to play on the
flanks and here this is f form in such a
stable center situation if you can
expand on the flanks this is good for
you and the fact that this position is
closed at the moment it's not really a
big problem for white the bishops are
also not particularly bad in close
positions especially not in close
positions that are actually let's say
moving forward yeah if the position is
not totally rigid then the bishops often
do a very good job in supporting the
pawns are pushing forward this explains
why aronian here does not want to keep
the position close at all quite the
opposite he plays his six to prepare the
hive busting the position open so how
does that feel logical we have to open
the
position against the bishops the thing
is what black hairs he's better
developed and he tries to accelerate the
game in a way and make some use of his
notes we see after Knight f3 that white
is directly attacking this and we get
some kind of tension here if white plays
in a more conservative way like an ID to
then black will play d 5 and this
position let's say castles 96 shows what
blacks ideas both nights now have good
central squares and those parts they are
not very dangerous at the moment if what
advances here let's say d4 for example
then black is happily Oh opening up the
position even more something like this
and this is very very active for black
yes it's an open position white has two
bishops but black's pieces are all
active and he has more pieces in play at
the moment him this is so back on c1 so
in a way sometimes you can also describe
that bishops want positions that are
usually a little bit more slow
developing yeah and not in they
shouldn't have a huge um yeah tonight's
need acceleration in a way yeah they
should be used in a quick way if you
have a better development it's often
better for the bishops to have some time
to yet to get them in position let's say
and here black tries to let's say be
quicker and try to not allow the bishops
become into good positions yeah in the
game this Knight f3 plate and Knight
takes e4 castles and white gets this
pawn back only five year after d6 he
plays Knight xe5 um the an ID c5 now
this is a new move actually there has
been a game between geary and islands
where on earth took only five however
after Bishop takes e4 he was slightly
worse and in fact
I'm pretty quickly blundered in that
game against scurvy with Bishop u6 after
which Bishop a three rookie aid Queen B
what happened to end simply two pawns
are hanging yeah so this is the novelty
by aronia and they both them probably
had seen this position before it's a
pretty funny sequence here with f5f
forehead while playing default yeah or
this is shane relatively a forced check
chad we get this ending now where with
white being a porn down but he has a
compensation in terms of the of the
bishop pair so it difficult to black to
ever try to get make something out of
his pawn white is just a bit too active
and we quickly see those trades
happening white wanna pawn but the
actual extra point is well maybe c3 and
that doesn't look very relevant however
still it feels like white should be able
to press a little bit due to his more
active pieces the bishop has a bit more
active and the rookie as well especially
this idea pushing the a porn and maybe
getting at the c64 seems dangerous it
feels like maybe there should be
something for swidler but in the game
aronia defended check at the end yeah so
around here you feel like maybe there's
something but black gets his back gets
on the 8th ultimately this is a draw now
the computer is not very convinced but
if you give it some time and I mean the
human can assesses I think pretty clear
the other black rook and the porn here
they are not let's say attackable by the
White King so this is kind of a
self-sufficient construction the rook is
always looking at this point so it
cannot promote em
legacy staying on the King side so this
is a draw and they agreed after that
move yeah maybe there was something for
swidler it felt like it was a little bit
better but it wasn't something very
obvious let's say or something that
commentators pointed out also it's not
like the engine is like the ofrenda clay
blinking at some point is I there was a
win ok the next game I want to check its
Nakamura Giri however I want to just
look at this very very briefly not
because the game looks uninteresting but
because it was played in like 40 minutes
and both both players clearly you the
whole game from the whole preparation
they had a semi Slav this is a very
common opening line right advances in
the center and around here tactics
tactics beginner the age to port hangs
so g3 rookie eight and nine f5 yeah
black hose Bishop c5 bishop a form Queen
to be six and King to g2 yeah to show
that there's a history with the players
he involved in this position the move
Knight takes f 2 I was played by by
shear off against Aguirre yeah in 2014
in and I think they played a short match
of a couple of games in joven probably
mispronouncing they're terribly and the
Netherlands and after you five Giri got
a very strong attack and ultimately
after 97 before it did super super sharp
stuff 9594 could have got a strong
attack so this is clearly was part of
the cameras preparation he could have
anticipated this position is giving
had this on the board with wide gap you
also always check what the other guy
plays with wide and they very often play
them openings from both sides of the
board so King g2 played by nakamura and
now Giri improves on that night XF to
replace the move g6 an h3
counter-attacking the night and now
Knight e5 was played this is the novelty
yeah technically speaking the novelty
there was another game with Shiro
involved through those 15 where sheriff
took on f5 yeah and now the thing is the
next moves and the game last further 30
news is all the main line of any engine
and it is basically given always
instantly and they just played that very
quickly and yeah it feels kind of
pointless for teacher to analyzes in a
way because they're not even to play us
at the board playing they just rapid use
what their computers told them yeah
black now it doesn't have much of an
alternative it's also very
straightforward that's your form there's
a threat on e3 so white has to take it
f5 getting that play against the king
see five-year opening up the the bishop
it's all rather they've logic looking
and not totally irrational moves check
at night f7 yeah and again this looks
like a very sharp and interesting
position that the problem is that after
group to f8 now White has no alternative
to play 95 and after 95 also black
cannot do much else the queen is
attacked if you take it's not very
advisable it's a check so the Queen has
to kept showing me too and now we see
the draw 97 check King goes back yeah
when what else have you don't want to do
this checkmate
so back check and check yeah and the
King cannot go here here as check this
is also pretty embarrassing check losing
the queen so I like this where do you
want to go yeah well he went to g6 can
you go back here yes you can but there's
also a drone yeah check check check and
check so they change anything at 22
times and now I'm agree to a draw so
what to make of such a game it's always
a little bit difficult yeah first of all
it's not very exciting for the spectator
edge is a quick it's a quick draw
ultimately it looks like an interesting
game but it's mostly reproduction of
things and what to make of this of this
game I mean from blacks perspective you
often get yep Giri often gets some kind
of yeah bad press for playing many
drawers but you know he's black here and
it's absolutely not his problem yeah if
he's got black in such an event draw is
basically not a bad result and in this
particular line also seems very
difficult to deviate but what exactly
wasn't a camera as a gender here yeah
maybe he knew that this would be
ultimately a draw I mean this particular
line with perfect play and he just
wanted to test Giri if he announced that
particular line and play a very low-risk
kind of game here with the with the draw
in hand this kind of strategy sometimes
is quite successful it has been used by
the camera before he played a very sharp
game I'm not sure that one or two years
ago I think one year ago against i think
it was kayaking and kayak and simply
forgot what he had prepared two or three
years before and that supposedly drawing
line all of a sudden 14 nakamura because
opponent forgot his preparation maybe
that was a try yeah just to play it safe
and keep
play with the drawing end but ultimately
a pretty disappointing game okay kawana
to paul off is next and this is actually
interesting game at least the end of it
they had an italian game caruana avoids
a further berlin that seems that to
paula was very much insisting on playing
classical openings here he also plays an
idol over some other Sicilians but not
in this event so far a bit surprising i
thought maybe round for you already
wasn't minus 2 at that point um that he
yeah what that he tries to sharpen it up
a little bit but doesn't seem to be the
case okay the italian game karana
doesn't want to build it and we get a
pretty standard italian a for this is a
somewhat topical idea nowadays the idea
is to play an early night a three and
get the night over to e3 in that way
yeah not via d to f1 III yeah it's an
interesting little twist why not rupee
eight now i don't want to talk so much
about this i think it's all rather
logical yeah they very often you see
those trades white now if we should be
five avoided further trades to keep some
kind of tension again here karana kidney
doesn't just want to want to exchange
the whole board let's say and make it
wrong now we see the symmetrical
tendency Siena the pawn structure here
is entirely symmetrical the only
difference is with the pieces how the
pieces are positioned and I think of
anybody white does have a little
something but it is not much he gets in
d4 not apart of gets to trade one pair
of pieces this is not like playing for
drawers playing boringly it's just what
you have to do if
have a little bit less space it all
makes sense to trade yeah all very
logical b6 it tries to put as many
points as possible on the dark squares
which is typical player with the bishop
on a light square replacing the pawns on
dark squares is pretty normal way of
setting up your pawn structure yeah why
don't when t5 and now look a one yeah
looks a bit passive to cover that porn
but he knows that he will play before
very quickly here we go night FY it's
not a good idea here for black to snatch
a poor Nia after something like this and
take second bag and rook here this will
be falling and then be six is very weak
so black tries to keep this pawn
structure intact night and for takes
here rupee one and Bishop b5 here all
looks quite normal white would like to
trade that Bishop and also if in case
here a black would take then we are
happily getting a pass up so black goes
back to c8 it doesn't take and now
Bishop f1 good prophylactic move this
kind of night is always annoying and
with Bishop f1 on a very good day we
might even get in g3 but first of all
it's a good protection or where the
bishop is a good good defender yeah f 5
by 2 pi love now we see who thinks he'll
sing the heating up and now very good
move i think by Kara wanna he notices it
that if Black gets to take on e4 the d5
pawn becomes very weak and so he plays
see for this is not such an easy move to
make because it looks rather unfriendly
act towards the f1 Bishop but this is
simply a case of yeah you have to do
yeah otherwise d 5 becomes a bit too
weak and it's not such a big deal that
Bishop is not entirely bad for example
you can imagine that if those two pawns
are trading and very likely this is
happening now or very shortly then the
bishop has chances to get out via d3
sometimes also why i like-- h4 g3 bishop
h3 also the possible thing this is not a
completely banned bishop okay black
plate review to f7 look a three
potentially trying to double every
through a to b 3 yeah and the next move
by 2 pi love is not very precise i think
the engine recommendation Bishop d7 is
pretty good it has a look at this pawn
and this makes rook age would be 3 an
unattractive IDM also after Bishop
deceptive white captures black
recaptures and actually gains a tempo on
that rook that is also fine from black
what he did is he captured and this
doesn't seem to be so precise now knight
takes Bishop f5 and now look a to be
three yeah and it starts to get slightly
slightly annoying for black he has to be
super precise now engines recommend nite
nite h5 now or queen to d7 it's both not
lots of fun yeah that was already a
little bit emphasized to allow y tu to
get that doubling on the befallen what
he plays Bishop g6 definitely leads into
trouble after room to be six it just d6
is weak and what exactly is black
supposed to do now the relatively best
choice even though absolutely not fun is
maybe to take on e4 I mean this is not a
would you love to play but does at least
relieves some of the pressure on the d6
porn what white is already quite quite
clearly actually better this is what you
did Queen to e7 and this is leading to a
losing position white can take on d6 and
black now is objectively speaking lost
yeah he took on a tree trying to
complicate matters that's the best
practical choice probably something like
this should be one is just losing after
night f7 without any particular chance
this is hanging and let's say I'm Cree
takes rook takes and yeah there is no
there's no counter play the queen is
nicely covering squares the bishop is
covering this white is just winning yeah
this is what two part of tried it's more
38 that's an important information so
it's all about the term trouble and
Queen takes good this wasn't good at all
yeah here black is actually better we
don't need to analyze that much because
this is also quite I mean this is the
obvious move I think Queen takes yeah
and now what is black supposed to do now
yeah his rook is attacked he's a piece
down first to the hall yeah his rook
hangs and after Luke takes f 2 there is
nice eight and this is a big issue now
this is also hanging and the queen is
hanging and black well what is he
supposed to do this I could take on just
sexy yeah s night takes oops check like
retakes s-97 or chat like routine here
check and here white is also winning
this is protected and after just check
just back and nothing happens
yeah black is lost it's just hit just
what it is it's lost yeah rook f6 was
played by to pull off and again night c8
is happening the same move that we saw
earlier Queen to d8 yeah and now this is
move 41 this is very important kawana
now was not in time pressure anymore he
now has time to to figure this out and
yeah what can you say he plays want to
be five and this move is very difficult
to understand I mean it's it mean I know
it's one thing to play under this kind
of psychological pressure and so on and
to sit at home but there's really no big
big difficulty in figuring out that you
have six wins it's the most obvious move
let's say it's something that you
definitely check yeah this is pretty
straightforward stuff yeah let's really
no no big effort in determining that as
a win and after qui takes rook b2 is
also kind of clear how else are you
going to defend the f porn yeah and it's
just a situation where white is a piece
of it's just like that black can try to
push here but after f3 there's nothing
happening I'm not quite sure what
Carolina's miss was I don't think it's
this move because this is this kind of
tactic is so easy for players of that
strength I mean in particular I mean
it's very easy if you see it on the
board but what's in them the calculation
leading to that so it's really a bit
mysterious because rook f6 was a pretty
simple win yeah rook 1b5 was played and
now after rook takes f 2 nothing is
clear absolutely not yeah what is what
supposed to do now this is hanging with
check now if you if you'd move the
bishop black will take and
can take down the night I can play 25 in
both cases yeah black is completely okay
yeah he decided to take their tragic and
that's it for the extra piece that that
white had Jim really really hard to
figure out what went wrong there okay
why is no traded and here surprisingly
again Caryn opts for look to see six
instead of taking on 85 that was
possible and I think still netted white
very reasonable winning chances it's
equal material but those points here are
rather dangerous and far more advanced
then let's say this potential majority
of two against one the e porn the e porn
is a as an asset for black but the white
king is very close and will help to stop
that point which is not the case for
blacks King let's say in relation to the
airport here white has very good to any
chances I think or at least when you can
very very clearly try yeah after Lucas's
611 a black right here and now got the
eeport going and here it's already very
questionable if white can do anything at
all because the me porn is so dangerous
yeah okay one and now black comes comes
with this rook yeah look everyone is a
very serious idea adhere they agree to
draw y-yeah white basically has to how
do you college he has to end the game
now basically with g7 room takes rook
takes rook t form yeah and this would
end in a draw this is hanging now you
can continue this but they will be very
likely some kind of Perpetual like
Brooks is seven ok for and c6 c4e 70 G
for ya and ya this will will end in a
will end in a draw and it ended in a
draw the game was was finished after
Rookie of age ok yeah this video as
usual gets longer than I intended so
next game is kayaking are not here we go
where is it kayaking are not okay and an
interesting open here and ready and
ready system with the uncommon move
order with III yeah the main point of
III is I guess that he didn't want to go
see for immediately so that black and
Anand does not have a default an option
that move is surprisingly rarely played
even though I think it is a very decent
option for black its ambitious but also
I think quite promising but this is
prevented by kayaking with e3 of course
he gives up or any ideas to combine than
c4 and g3 but still Knight f6 c4e 6mb
you three yeah it doesn't look so
exciting right but to be perfectly
honest I think
games from openings like that quite
often nowadays on the top level tend to
be more interesting than games from
sharp-looking openings because here we
actually quite often see play over the
board without that much preparation and
also play where um yeah more pieces I
kept on the board this in fact will lead
to a very interesting position and
captures on d5 interesting ya know
island has a choice you can take with
the e pawn and go for an isolated Queen
point position after D 496 this is
definitely not bad for black and was a
quite viable option no the iqp positions
from the tirage defense of the Queens
gambit declined they are usually I'd
with a little bit of suspicion on their
own the highest level but yep white is
committed to this set up already and he
also has not been carried his bishop so
this should be quite ok for black are
not placed with the night however but
it's not a bad move i'm just saying that
he takes d5 was quite a valid ID mm
Quincy 296 and you can ask him what
exactly is why it's point yeah what what
is doing here he keeps the center pawns
flexible and he now goes for some flank
action with the move h4 that's quite
interesting that idea is well known and
especially from the Sicilian defense
with them with reverse colors yeah for
example if blacks porn would be on e5
here in this pollution then it would
look a lot like some Sicilian with
reversed colors the idea with h4 is
really as primitive as it as it looks 95
try to checkmate black it's a dangerous
a little bit yeah we shouldn't
underestimate ideas also related with
this bishop if black now and honored
directly
reacted to the move after you went b6 we
can play that for us there be 6 a-3 now
we directly um reacted to the move by
playing f5 yeah what happens in this
position if black plays let's say Bishop
to be 7 some kind of some kind of normal
standard looking move yeah there is 95
and this is really a problem for black
if he goes Knight f6 to cover that then
924 becomes a problem right now
threatens the night f6 and queen h7 meet
and tactics are already popping up here
this this g6 for example there's night x
e6 and white wins check this is a
complete disaster but it has pretty cool
lines g5 96 for example is one of them
and tier rugae 8 mate is around the
corner or wide winning back like
everything very nice 95 is a serious
idea it really is you cannot argue if f5
was really necessary I mean black for
example also had a move like Knight to
f6 there that shields or covers age 7
for the time being and it's also not
looking that bad White has ideas yeah
9594 okay f5 the drawbacks of the move
our the drawback main drawback of the
movers just what we all know pawns
cannot go back it weakens black
structure quite a bit Bishop b5 this
should be 795 here black also had Queen
takes d5 a move that looks maybe a
little bit shaky to position the Queen
and rukia on the same diagonal but
to Bishop c4 Queen back it doesn't feel
like why can do much directly here black
also seems to be okay and i took with
the porno ever and now after d4 um i
think the opportunity now he skips an
opportunity that is pointed out by am by
the engine it's not a very intuitive at
dma before human player but it's
interesting you could have played c4 in
this position the idea is that after be
takes a six can be can be played and
this leads to very interesting plane if
white now takes he's a phone up but
after let's say it's five black has the
idea f1 and this leads to a very
complicated play where black has quite
lots of yeah counter chances note that
the position is messy and this Bishop
can prove to be very useful there are a
couple of other other possibilities why
can also go back to a 4 here in this
line after which blackheads b5 funny
idea the idea is that this is this this
check drops a piece but wyd of course
can go back here and now black has
Knight a5 or the move before in both
cases he has rather decent play for the
pawn it's however not a very intuitive
decision and not very obvious or
anything like that it was an interesting
option though that shows that blacks
position is not completely bad rook c8
in a white capture on c5 and castles
yeah shows that white is not completely
married to the idea
of giving checkmate here on the King
side he just is content with playing
this position so why is this position
easier to play for white the reason is
those three pawns have moved and have
left quite a number of weaknesses behind
like the pawns themselves can be weak
but also squares like e6 d 6 c 6-r
potentially week where whites position
is more compact he doesn't have clear
weaknesses in its position this position
is easier for white and we see in the
game that after a couple of further
trades then we have this traded and the
bishops traded you see that white now
has a couple of ideas you can use the e5
square which is weak yeah black very
much would like here to play f5 to f6
back maybe or I have 52 f 7 yeah but the
porn being on f5 is just absolutely not
helping and we have the hanging porns
that cannot easily push forward at the
moment you know after White's next
regrouping there was so much pressure on
the c5 porn then uh none felt obliged to
push but after takes takes Queen e5
white now definitely enjoys the better
game I mean I think what actually was a
little bit better the whole time but now
it gets to be rather apparent yeah what
the problem is those pawns are just
loose and weak and black is suffering
quite a bit and try to keep discovered
he traded trade try g6 but see how this
works yeah the rook is coming here and
has pressure against both pawns it's an
enormously a comfortable position for
black check
it's a simple threats check the night is
coming over here so that no black
schneider also was forced into an into
passive position ya can just repeat once
but not 3 times please yeah position is
absolutely Badham white is also
intending this and maybe take that pawn
at the right moment but one issue is
also wide can improve its position so
easily and effortlessly yeah King can
approach for example it's very very very
awkward yeah in this move doesn't help
him but blacks position was very very
bad he's 693 and here are not already
resides yes absolutely no good reply by
the threatening this and rook to take
the seven so you cannot move the King
just to show the idea Jack because of
this and if you move the rook where do
you want to go and let's say here than
just 95 and next wide we'll take a
couple of times on e7 and win the king
and porn ending so a pretty pretty
awkward looking loss for Arnold who got
into a bad position out of this
unconventional opening you can maybe
slightly question f5 if that is
necessary and it may be here queen d 5 1
suppose advisor decision even though
also here black has slight issues here
with this with the structure I'd rather
be why it still I think a very good game
by kayaking and a very good preparation
a very good idea in terms of how to get
some game going without a boatload of
hearing and post some interesting
problems here with this with this age
form very interesting way of playing
yeah you know what I'm kind of
not very satisfied with I would like to
understand better how black could have
better defended here I mean I think that
blacks position is slightly awkward but
my hunch and this is that maybe you
shouldn't have traded some so so many
pieces the the bishop yeah he trained
bishops on f6 and bishops on a6 later
but I'm absolutely not sure I don't
think it should be so terrible for black
but it is absolutely difficult to play
over the board without any doubt as we
have seen a vision really got into
trouble quite quite quickly ok I'm
changing my plans and not doing a round
four and five in this video I'm calling
it a day here and do a separate video
for round five and then it's up with 14
on six to not make it too long so even
though I tried to keep it to keep it
brief it got 40 minutes again anyway I
hope you enjoyed the somewhat late
coverage of Round four and also make
sure to check around five and road six
thanks for watching guys